joining us here now on the rich eisen
show getting ready to be part of the
mega cast portion of monday night
football's finale to super wild card
weekend you got the game on espn and abc
you got the manning cast and got the
mega cast with the crew of nfl live and
that includes dan orlowski back here in
the rich eisen show how you doing dan
i'm fantastic bud good to link up with
you and as these playoffs start and talk
a little football yes absolutely there
is so much to discuss the most
impressive performance of the weekend to
date is fill in that blank sir oh
yeah josh allen in in his performance
you know against new england patriot
defense that was you know one of the top
two in another football this season
um you know when when josh is used that
way rich when i say used that way the
way you know brian gable has really
started to deploy him this last four
week five week stretch you know where
uh there's when he's used that way he's
almost indefensible and i kind of i said
this he he's like shohei ohtani you know
the basically do-it-all player for the
angels because
you know if you want josh to play
against zone defense where they're going
to give you completions he'll take them
and then you need a quarterback with a
big powerful arm to drive the football
downfield and take shots he can do it
you need a quarterback that he's got
strong enough arm and good enough
velocity to throw these 18 to 25 yard
deep crossing routes versus man coverage
he could do it
you want a quarterback that
um you know you want to utilize in your
designed run game you know it could be
effective he can do it you want a
quarterback to get himself out of
trouble when the protection's not great
he could do that you know he's a he's a
three-tool quarterback he can beat you
with his arm beat you with his legs and
beat you with his mind and um
when they use him like that and he's
rolling like that man he's just an
indefensible player well i mean and the
fact that you didn't stutter when you
said josh allen as the most impressive
performance
and and it just shows you just how
impressive it was when mahomes threw
five touchdowns in ten and a half
minutes against the steelers defense
you know on sunday night not too shabby
we don't even talk about it anymore when
patrick does that i i think the quality
of defense is probably the big
difference for me i mean you know
pittsburgh's defense is falling off so
much patrick was really good patrick's
been really good for about the last six
weeks it's so nice to see him
clean up some of the stuff that was
hampering him really at the start of the
season but the way josh just absolutely
dominated that game
um was so eye-opening dan orlovsky here
on the rich eisen show the uh cowboys
loss you lay that at whose feet
if there's a foot later yeah i think
it's 100 on mike mccarthy um and 100 on
dak prescott
no honestly right i think it's like a
marriage we ain't given 50 50. it's 100.
all right so
listen it's my my truthful answer like
my non kind of joking answer
this falls on 400 million dollars of
offense
you're you're a 140 million dollar
quarterback rich there's three guys at
that position in the nfl that make 40
million dollars a year we just talked
about two of them josh allen and patrick
mahomes and dak prescott josh allen and
patrick went for over 400 yards that
couldn't play good they didn't play well
enough
yeah and
in those moments that's what you're paid
for is to to outperform when no one else
on your offense shows up your 90 million
dollar back didn't show up again your
100 million dollar receiver and amari
cooper didn't show up again
you know candidly tyron smith got beat
up yesterday he got he got handled by
the 49ers defensive front they just you
don't you don't get into the end game
situation and
and how that game ended by playing well
on offense no one played good
offensively um
but the way the game went rich
and the fake punt and the
lack of communication and the confusion
after the fake punt that delay a game
they don't get a first down after that
because of that five yard penalty right
and obviously the way the end of the
game is handled and the lack of
preparation and and the lack of a plan
that's got to fall at the feet of mike
mccarthy and
listen
the truth of mike mccarthy is this two
years as dallas cowboys head coach he's
18 and 15. with zach prescott as his
starting quarterback
outside of the nfc east they're six and
nine together
outside of the worst division in
football there are six and nine together
and
that's not that for our owner who came
out last weekend said super bowl or bus
man i just don't see how that's good
enough well and then in terms of the the
last play um
dan dan orlowski here on the rich eisen
show the conversation from both mccarthy
and dak is that we've we drilled it
we've practiced it we've done this we've
done that in in practicing this does
somebody play the role of the official
the umpire because you know so much is
made of the umpire bumped dak and we had
mike pereira on in hour number one of
the show
dan and he said that the umpire should
not have
re-spotted the football just touch the
ball and get the hell out of the way
but put it all together though uh if you
find the official like larry fitzgerald
for instance always did and chase
claypool famously did not earlier this
year
then maybe that doesn't happen is there
a role of an official in drilling this
to make sure that the quarterback
doesn't hand the ball to the center to
self-spot
you know oh okay so yeah this is a great
question there's a lot to it so first of
all um everyone plays their part in the
end game of situation 100 the officials
got to be you know in the right place
knowing where the football is knowing
what his role is but i'm going to just
walk you through rich kind of how this
gets taught in the locker room so you
reference larry fitzgerald if you go
back and watch some of the moments with
larry larry takes the ball from the edge
of the field right outside the numbers
receiver wise sprints in and multiple
times actually hands the ball to the
center the center then turns and hands
it to the official that tells me
everybody in the office is aware
certainly the person snapping the
football that the official has to touch
the ball all right so in that situation
14 seconds is what's on the clock i've
always learned that 16 seconds was like
that okay that's our cutoff 14 seconds
is the near death experience that's the
the max that we can go okay
so once you make that decision number
one ball carrier whoever you are
receiver tight end tailback quarterback
we're just trying to get some yards not
all the yards you got to do a good job
of declaring yourself down because you
trying to get two or three extra yards
is worth an extra second or two so
number one dak prescott went too far
number two your job is to get up and
hand the ball to the official don't toss
it to them these guys are 60 years old
i'm not knocking someone who's 60 but in
the heat of the moment everyone's moving
around you don't want to trust the guy
to catch the ball from you you hand the
football to him okay number three
everyone then needs to be with urgency
to get into a legal formation if you go
watch like noah brown or dalton schultz
they're like confused in that moment
five seconds on the clock hey what are
we doing so it looks lack of preparation
and then the last point then this is one
of the most crucial for me rich so again
when you're taught this situation
that's if things go ideally right hey if
everything goes perfectly
you're always taught as a quarterback
what happens if it doesn't go the way we
hope let's say there's a stumble or the
referee does hold the football
three seconds is the cutoff where if you
realize the clock is on three seconds
you are now in 9-1-1 mode you are
screaming down the field or at the line
of scrimmage 9-1-1 9-1-1 that is
declaring to everybody we are not
spiking the football we are in a hail
mary situation we're running down to the
end zone
that was never part of what it looked to
be the cowboys preparation and so
there's so many layers when you would do
this in practice there should always be
an official we've always had officials
to be a part of that it's never been you
know a player it's always been the
officials and it just looked like the
cowboys were unprepared and and and not
um able to execute what was necessary
dan orlowski here on the rich eisen show
so then last one for you on the subject
matter and you've heard all the
conversations since by the way i i i
have been uh on uh uh
the bystander status when michael irvin
gets at it with somebody on the set as
happened to you today on first take uh
with steven a's return perfect timing by
the way too
um so what what do you do if you're
jerry jones
what do you do
yeah i i think it's hard to bring back
mike mccarthy i really do um i thought
ed werner made a great point on get up
this morning when he was asked that
question and he said i don't want to get
into hypotheticals or whatnot and then
you know greeny push back on well kellen
moore and he said well i actually think
dan quinn's probably the
part of this conversation that is more
likely because he thinks it's more
likely dan quinn is going to be
a head coach again before kellen moore
is for the first time and are you
willing to lose potentially dan quinn if
you're jerry jones i laid out like if if
we go back think about this rich like we
can go back week two against the
chargers when the clock runs out that
mike mccarthy said well we couldn't see
the clock week three against the eagles
before halftime the clock runs all the
way out with like a minute 50 and a half
they never call time out week six
against the patriots they called him out
to kick a field goal with 24 seconds
left rather than letting the clock won
all the way down week 15 he throws the
ball to dalton schultz and and they
don't take a shot at the end zone
because he says that they're in the
ozone week 17
last week against the or two weeks away
from the cardinals he calls time on he
can't challenge the fumble
i think it's hard given what the record
is given what the performance is given
what the reality of this this poor game
and clock management i think it's hard
to bring back mike mccarthy to this
football team
danarolovsky here on the rich eisen show
uh you're concerned about which
quarterback moving forward more mac
jones jalen hurts what do you got for me
on that one
um
probably jalen hurts
um
i think that jalen hurts
did so much good this year i've been
outspoken i think jalen hurts has done
enough to be the starting quarterback
for the philadelphia eagles next year
um
i still say two things for jalen
and he's still such a very young player
but guys in the nfl you can't wait till
they're open you've got to see them open
before they are and he's not there yet
and the second thing is his arm strength
is a thing his arm's just not that
powerful
and
you know you've got to figure out as an
organization how comfortable you are
with that reality
um i think max did so many good things
now you could say the same thing with
mac average arm strength but mac has so
such other things in his game how fast
he plays
how quickly he gets the ball out uh how
much of an anticipation thrower he is
that that kind of elite trait or those
elite traits will mask the average
armstrong so i'd say jalen hurts and
then just again because what happened
with the cowboys and then obviously
burroughs first performance and how the
raiders still almost won that game and
mahomes and big bends farewell and and
so on and so forth uh
you know i i can you overlook tom brady
i mean because
i mean even with no fournette and no
ronald jones and no godwin and no
antonio brown they he he still put up 30
on the eagles
yesterday he's incredible it's remar
it's unbelievable
damn he's
he's mine
it boggles my mind not only the
performance rich and i've always felt
this way about him
how much every single play matters to
him
i just i i don't i can't even
conceptualize the level of expectation
for excellence he has every single play
every single play you see him miss a
throw he gets frustrated with himself
you see a guy not do what he's expecting
it he gets visibly upset
and it's it's fascinating it's
fascinating to me i i you know tom is
i'm so intrigued by the bucks right now
um because of the injuries uh
but at the same time
i that offensive line of tristan works
is healthy
and those he's got two gold jackets
thrown through still and he still has
mike evans and rob gronkowski i think
mike evans is going to be a hall of
famer so i can't
i can't sit here and say
i'm discounting tampa bay getting back
strictly because of who the quarterback
is and strictly because i think they're
good enough on offense well i mean look
uh
we might find out as i said at the top
of the show that uh
that uh the team that many in the nfc
would be upset with the most are the
rams because they had the niners dead to
rights and let them off the hook
and now the cowboys are out and we might
find out that the packers will feel the
same way at this very point next weekend
you never know
and the bucks are sitting there at home
they're going to get the winner of
monday night football a west coast team
on a short week
coming all the way across the country
and they're the two seed sitting back
they might not have to move all the way
up to the super bowl it's entirely
possible that that's the case for tampa
right now
dan 100
100 the the the way you know if your
green bay you're sitting there going
seriously like this was the if i had to
sit down and script out
how to beat the green bay packers or how
to attack and beat or what's the
weakness of green bay i would just copy
and paste the san francisco 49ers
and that's why green bay's got to be
saying they're going you got to be
kidding me
um you know i i this is why this we had
this season though rich right this is
why we had this season where you know we
live in the world where every week you
get asked the question well who's who do
you think's the best team in the nfc or
you know who's the biggest threat to the
chiefs and
i think many of us try to be confident
in right in our answer and got to the
point was like i don't know i feel like
a lot of teams are you know and i think
that's what the beauty is where we sit
with with this final eight right now is
i don't i don't know if anybody would be
surprised if any of the eight ran the
super bowl last one for you then what
happens tonight what's your best guess
as to what happens this evening
in los angeles i think the rams win
because they're the better football team
i think that i have said this this is
the biggest game in the history of
matthew stafford's career and if he wins
it next week is the biggest game in
history matthew stafford's career this
is a
legacy changing three-week stretch for
him and if he plays three clean
he'll be a hall of famer uh and if he
doesn't that the noise is going to be
very loud on the outside i think tonight
number one
uh i would put two tight ends on the
field and i would run the football
and my outside zone game against arizona
they've proven it all year that they
cannot stop it i would force the coroner
up uh to the boundary to so that he can
cover odell beckham one on one
i know cooper cub's gonna get his
and i think if you can protect the
safeties if you're the rams if you could
protect your safeties that are unproven
and and kind of your backups
you should win this football game
because you're the better team
dan enjoy tonight man in the seven years
that i was at espn if you had told any
single human being walking around there
that that you would be
or espn would have a monday night
football playoff game
and then have the mannings part of it
and then have the country watch it on a
whole bunch of networks including what
you've got
uh streaming on espn plus tonight nobody
would have believed it man nobody so
it's the truth what a big night what a
big night for the worldwide leader big
night so enjoy it enjoy it i appreciate
you brother thank you for that no no
it's the truth soak it in and uh you
know you've got a great crew and have
fun just have a blast it's gonna be
great thanks bud you're the best man
thank you right back at you at
danarolovsky7 on twitter i follow him
you should as well right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here